OF THE PUBLIC WELCOME TO THE
SOMEBODY PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE.
FIRST WE HAVE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS WITH THE ABSENCE
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
TODAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE WILL
BE SUBSTITUTING TODAY.
AND ONCE SHE JOINS US.
ALSO WE HAVE FIFTY ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. THREE OF THESE ITEMS
HAVE BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
THEY ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
THIRTY THREE BONTA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B.
NINE SEVEN NINE RIGHT AS AN FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT STONE.
ALSO WE ARE FOR ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THEY ARE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
THREE SEVEN TWO VOEPEL.
SIX FOUR FOUR AS THE COMMITTEE --
BILL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B. SIX SEVEN
SIX SIX SIX SEVEN TWO ARMS ARE
CERVANTES.
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN A.
B. FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO O'DONNELL.
AND WITH THAT ARE DO WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL
THE ROLL.
IT JUST OPTION FORM [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ HERE [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
AND HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
CONCERT CALENDAR.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
SECRETARY PROBLEM [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
YES [inaudible] EIGHT LEVINE
[inaudible]
COOLEY -- SINCE I'VE CONSENT.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
PHONE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
THEN CONSENT CALENDARS OUT AND
WITH THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
START WITH OUR FIRST MEMBER I
THINK WE HAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS COME FORTH.
WHAT FILE ITEM IS A? THIRTEEN A
THIRD.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN FOR DRONE SORT.
SO WHEN YOU'RE READY SURE THANK
YOU FOR CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
CURRENT LAW DEFINES TWO
DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS MERIT
DISTRICTS AND NON MERIT
DISTRICTS CLASSIFIED CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ARE CRUCIAL TO OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM BY
PROVIDING HEALTH NUTRITION AND
ECONOMIC SUPPORT FOR SERVICES.
ALL THE CLASSIFIED WORK IS
COMPLETED BY THE SAME STANDARD
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
DISTRICT IS MERIT FOR NON MERIT.
NOT MERIT DISTRICTS HAVE A
LONGER PROBATIONARY PERIOD OF
ONE YEAR.
WHERE AND MERIT DISTRICT ALLOWS
FOR SIX MONTH PROBATIONARY
PERIOD MY BILL AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE WILL BRING CONFORMITY AND
CLARITY DECATUR TOUGH CLASSIFIED
STAFF BY ALLOWING? FOR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IN NON
MERIT DISTRICTS TO OBTAIN
PERMANENT STATUS NO LATER THAN
SIX MONTHS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NON MERIT
DISTRICTS ALREADY CONFORMING TO
THE MERIT DISTRICT TIME LIMITS
DUE TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS.
ALIGNING BOTH OF THESE CODE
SECTIONS SIMPLIFIES THE PROCESS.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THEY HAVE RAISED WE
PLAN TO CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSIONS
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ENTERED INTRODUCE.
OUR WITNESS CHRIS DIPLOMA.
THANKING.
UP MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTY
BOMB ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
US STANDING IN FOR TRISTEN BROWN
WHILE HE IS AWAY ON LEAVE -- WE
ARE PLEASED TO BE SPONSORS OF
THIS MEASURE.
THIS IS JUST ABOUT PARITY FOR
CLASSIFIED SERVICE EMPLOYEES.
OF THEIR WORK IS COMPLETED TO
THE SAME STANDARDS WHETHER THEY
WORK FOR MAYOR TO STRICT OR NON
MERIT DISTRICT OF THEY SUFFER
THE SAME.
INSTABILITY ABOUT NOT BEING
RETURNED EMPLOYMENT OVER SUMMER
BREAK IT'S JUST A FAIRNESS ISSUE
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR
DO HAVE SOMEBODY OR OPPOSITION.
OKAY COMPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND WITH APOLOGIES TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WAX ARE NOW ARE UP.
A POSITION WAS TOO LATE TO BE
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS -- WE
DO OPPOSE THE BILL I'M JEFF BACA
WITH THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS -- AT
RC A WE WE HAVE ABOUT SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
WE VALUE THEM VERY HIGHLY -- WE
DO WHAT WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE.
A COMPLETE AN INTEGRATED PART OF
THE EDUCATIONAL ENTERPRISE.
A WE ARE CONCERNED WITH.
MANDATING AND STATUTE A MAXIMUM
A PROBATIONARY PERIOD OF SIX
MONTHS.
IN OUR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT WITH OUR CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION.
WE HAVE A SIX MONTH.
PROBATIONARY PERIOD FOR
EMPLOYEES THAT WORK FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE HOURS BUT WE
BUILT IN A VISION IN THE
CONTRACT THAT ALLOWS FOR THAT TO
BE EXTENDED FOR UP TO NINE
MONTHS.
IF THE EMPLOYEE IS SHOWING
PROMISE BUT WE FEEL THAT NEEDS A
LITTLE ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE IN
TERMS OF GAINING THE SKILLS THAT
THEY NEED. TO SUCCEED IN THE
POSITION SORKIN CERTAIN REALLY
IS THAT BY MANDATING WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MERIT AND NON MERIT
DISTRICTS BUT BY MANDATING.
THE SIX MONTH PERIOD FOR A NON
MERIT DISTRICTS WERE CONCERNED
THAT THIS IN FACT WILL FORCE
DECISIONS ABOUT -- PERMITTED
EMPLOYEES THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE
DISADVANTAGES TO THOSE EMPLOYEES.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS DEREK
CLINICS ON BEHALF OF THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
ARE LETTER IS NOT REFLECTED IN
THE ANALYSIS AND THE REASON IS
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
YOUR STAFF ON THIS -- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST OPPOSED A
FOR TWO REASONS OUR CONCERNS ARE
FIRST THAT THE SIX MONTH TIME
PERIOD IS SIMPLY TOO SHORT TO
MAKE A PROPER EVALUATION OF THE
EMPLOYEE -- BOTH OUR EMPLOYERS
THAT WE'VE TALKED TO AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE EMPLOYEES THAT
THEY'VE CONFERRED WITH HAVE
AGREED THAT IT MAY NOT BE IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE EMPLOYEE
AND EMPLOYER. TO HAVE THE SIX
MONTHS ESPECIALLY WHERE SKILLED
TRADES ARE INVOLVED WHERE --
COMPLEX SECRETARIAL WORK OR
ANYTHING INVOLVING.
ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
MAY BE THAT DISADVANTAGEOUS. TO
SOMEBODY WHO'S ON A LEARNING
CURVE IN NEED THE ADDITIONAL
TIME SO HARD SIX MONTHS IS
DIFFICULT IN THAT SENSE AND THEN
THE SECOND REASON IS SIMPLY
BECAUSE EXISTING LAW ALREADY
ALLOWS DISTRICTS TO GO TO SIX
MONTHS.
OF THE PRIOR WITNESS MENTIONED A
NUMBER DISTRICTS GO BELOW THE
TWELVE MONTHS WE THINK IT'S
TOTALLY REASONABLE FOR DISTRICTS
IN THEIR BARGAINING PARTNERS TO
WORK OUT A SHORTER TIME PERIOD --
AND AND IT YOU KNOW UNDER
EXISTING LAW WE DON'T SEE ENOUGH
OF A REASON TO OVERTURN THESE
LOCALLY NEGOTIATED AGREEMENTS
ACROSS THE STATE -- AND SO FOR
THOSE TWO REASONS REGRETTABLY WE
MUST OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEN HEARING NONE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
MEASURE WHAT.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT TO THE
AUTHOR -- JUST SO YOU KNOW I'LL
BE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION HERE --
SUPPORT IN THE OFFICE OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT.
OKAY.
UNDERSTOOD.
SOME REMEMBER COOLEY HAD
QUESTION.
THERE'S A MOTION THEIR SECOND.
SOME REMEMBER LIKE CLOSER --
AGAIN WE JUST WANT TO BRING
CONFORMITY TO WHAT MANY
DISTRICTS ARE ALREADY DOING
HAPPY TO CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSION
WITH THE OPPOSITION WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK AFTER I VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I DO HAVE --
IRAQ ON THIS TO DO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT SAID SECRETARY
LIKE CALDERON THERE'S A MOTION
AND SECOND.
THE MOTION IS THE PATH.
RODRIGUEZ HI MY VEGAS I WILL
TELL.
THE BILL NO LEVINE [inaudible]
COOLEY. FIVE COOLEY AYE COOPER
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE.
WITH THAT SAID THAT WILL BE THE
ROLE OF THANK YOU [inaudible]
IS PATTERSON.
WITH THAT WE HAVE.
SOME REMEMBER PATTERSON.
FILE ITEM NUMBER. ELEVEN TWELVE
HUNDRED GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING FOR SURE AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWELVE HUNDRED IS A BILL TO
SIMPLY EXTEND.
CRYSTAL BLOWER PROTECTIONS TO
THOSE WHO CAN FIGHT IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHETHER AN
INDIVIDUAL MEMBER OR A
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE.
MY OFFICE HAS PERSONALLY
RECEIVED NUMEROUS COMPLAINTS
FROM STATE WORKERS AT VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS.
INFORMING ME OF ISSUES AND AN
APPROPRIATE ACTIVITY.
HOWEVER THEY FEAR FOR THEIR JOBS
AND WITHHOLD PERSONAL
INFORMATION -- BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THEY DO NOT RECEIVE ANY
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS WHEN
CONFIDING IN THE LEGISLATURE.
CURRENTLY SECTION EIGHT FIVE
FOUR SEVEN POINT TO THE
GOVERNMENT CODE PROTECTS STATE
WORKERS FROM RETALIATION WHEN
THEY REPORT ILLEGAL OR
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT TO THE
STATE AUDITOR OR THE CUT A
COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE.
AB TWELVE HUNDRED WILL ADD THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO THIS SECTION.
ALLOWING STATE WORKERS TO
CONFIDE IN THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES WITHOUT FEAR OF%
RETALIATION.
THIS LANGUAGE IS ALREADY IMPLIED
IN SECTION ELEVEN OH TWO POINT
FIVE OF THE LABOR CODE WHICH
OUTLINES WHICH WILL
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS. FOR
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYEES IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE THAT PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
BLOW THE WHISTLE ON
INAPPROPRIATE ACTIVITY AFTER
WORKPLACE WHICH IS WHY THIS
CHANGE. TO THE GOVERNMENT CODE
THAT IS NECESSARY.
OUT HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS A CAPTAIN
HUTCHINSON REPRESENTING CSU
EMPLOYEES UNION.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDES.
THANK YOU.
I ALSO WORK AT AT THE ISSUE
TENANTS IN CAMBRIA.
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
I PERSONALLY AT OUR CAMPUS WE
HADN'T PLAYED UP WITH RETALIATED
AGAINST THEY DID A WITH A BLOW
FOR FOR THE SHERRY.
AND THE MANAGER FOUND OUT INTO
MODE AT THE EMPLOYEE.
AND THAT A PLAY ENDED UP LEAVING --
AND SEVEN THIS ISSUE AND AND ONE
BUT AT OUR CAMPUS NOW THERE'S
FEAR OF ACTUALLY REPORTING A
WITH A BLOW WHEN THEY SEE THINGS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE --
OUR EMPLOYEES NOW NOW IF WE CAN
GO TO OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
OUR SENATORS AND TALK ABOUT
CERTAIN THINGS BUT WE GO THERE
TO SEE IF WE CAN GET HELP BUT
THEN WE ARE TOLD THERE'S NO
PROTECTION FOR US WHEN WE DO GO.
SO OUR PLACE IT IN SILENCE AND
SUFFER BECAUSE OF FEAR OF GOING
TO THE STATE AUDITOR AND NOT
HAVING THAT GUARANTEED
PROTECTION THAT WHEN THEY REPORT
SOMETHING.
THEY WON'T BE RETALIATED AGAINST
WHEN THEY GET BACK TO WORK SO
THAT IS WHY THE ISSUE OF PLACING
AN AND THAT.
THE FISHING POLE EITHER IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE OFFICE AND OR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
YES GO AHEAD ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY EXCELLENT
BAIL.
I WANNA FOR A SUGGESTED MEMON
ACTUALLY I LIKE I LIKE THE BILL
I LIKE THE BILL AS IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY.
A SIGNIFICANT DEGREE.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT ON
PAGES EIGHT AND NINE OF THE BILL
IT'S IN PRINT THE THE AMENDMENTS.
ON APRIL LATE.
THERE ARE THREE SECTIONS A
PARTICULAR NINETY ONE FORTY NINE
POINT.
TWO FOUR POINT.
TWO FIVE AND POINT.
TWO SIX THAT ACTUALLY WOULD HAVE
SERVED TO GIVE DIRECTION THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW THEY HANDLE
THESE SORTS OF THINGS.
SO I THINK THE BILL IS IS BEFORE
US IS EXCELLENT.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER A
MOTION IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THAT WE MOVING OUT TODAY AMENDED
TO REINSTATE.
NINETY ONE FORTY NINE POINT. TWO
FOUR TWO FIVE AND TWO SIX AS
THEY WERE PREVIOUSLY IN THE BILL.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND.
AND WITHOUT SOME REMEMBER YOU
WANTING TO TO THAT YET.
ABSOLUTELY -- I WANT.
TO THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
ALSO -- TO THE STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE AND MISSED COOLEY --
WE APPRECIATE THE POLISHING IN
THE SHINING IN THE AND THE
WORKING THIS BUILT A TO MAKE IT
EVEN BETTER.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
SO THISCOULD BE MOVED ALONG.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WITH THAT SAID.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A WE HAVE MOTION
SECOND SO THE MOTION IS. TO ADD.
NINE FOUR NINE ONE FOUR NINE
POINT TWO FOUR POINT TWO FIVE
AND POINT.
TWO SIX AND WITH THAT WE DO HAVE
THE MOTION SECOND SO SECRETARY
LIKE KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
RODRIGUEZ I REGUS AYE PROPEL I
HELLO I LEVINE.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER
FONG.
FONG I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL THANK THANK YOU MISTER
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH THANK
THANK YOU
.
OKAY WE'LL GO AHEAD WITH THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A. B.
TWELVE TWELVE AM STORING SO WHEN
YOU'RE READY SIR GO YEAH THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS AB TWELVE TWELVE
WOULD REQUIRE A STATE AGENCY
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
PRODUCE A LIST OF PRIORITY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS FOR
FUNDING CONSIDERATION.
BY PUBLIC PENSION RETIREMENT
BOARDS AND TO PROVIDE IT TO THEM.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE A STATE
AGENCY TO PROVIDE FURTHER
PROJECT INFORMATION TO A BOARD
ONLY UPON REQUEST THE BILL DOES
NOT.
REQUIRE ANY RETIREMENT BOARD TO
ACT IN ANY WAY ON THE
INFORMATION RECEIVED FROM THE
STATE AGENCY.
AS THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION NOTES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IT DOES NOT FORCE THE HANDS.
OF THE PENSION SYSTEMS TO MAKE
UNWISE INVESTMENTS.
IT SIMPLY REQUIRES STATE
AGENCIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
PROACTIVELY PROVIDE THE PENSION
SYSTEMS WITH THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO MAKE SOUND
INVESTMENT DECISIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING GAP THAT
IS GROWING EVERY DAY.
CALIFORNIA FORD ESTIMATES THAT
THE STATE WILL NEED TO SPEND.
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
DECADE JUST TO MEET OUR WATER
pINFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
LAST YEAR THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION SUBMITTED THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
THAT FOCUSES LIMITED AVAILABLE
RESOURCES ON CORE STATE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FURTHER
NOTED THE CONSTRUCTION AND
MAINTENANCE OF KEY PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS A CORE FUNCTION OF STATE
GOVERNMENT.
THERE CONTINUES TO BE A TO BE TO
BE CRITICAL DEFICIENCIES IN THE
STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE.
INCLUDING A SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG
OF MAINTENANCE ON EXISTING
FACILITIES AFTER YEARS OF UNDER
FUNDING.
THIS BILL COULD HELP REMEDY SOME
OF OUR CRITICAL.
INFRASTRUCTURE DEFICIENCIES WITH
ME TODAY IS STILL IN GIVENS OF
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
WHAT?
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DON'T GIVEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION --
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I'D WE'RE REALLY HAPPY TO SEE
THIS KIND OF LEGISLATION COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE I THINK
THAT TOO OFTEN WE'RE WE'RE
SEEING LEGISLATION COME BEFORE
THIS THIS COMMITTEE -- THAT
TELLS CALPERS HOW TO NOT SPEND
THEIR MONEY -- TELLS THEM HOW
NOT TO INVEST.
IN AND THIS IS ABOUT PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDING
INFORMATION. TO TO CALPERS
GIVING THEM.
THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
THAT MONEY WOULD STAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA GO TOWARDS CALIFORNIA
JOBS.
BENEFIT CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
IT THIS TYPE OF OF OF
LEGISLATION AND THE
ENCOURAGEMENT OF INVESTMENT IN
PROVIDING THE TOOLS NECESSARY.
IS VITAL TO OUR PENSION SYSTEMS
AND FOR THAT WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
DEAN HEDGING SILICON CALIFORNIA
CITIES ALLOW MY COMMENTS WITH
THE SPECIAL DISASSOCIATION APART
TO SEE THIS -- THIS BILL MOVE
FORWARD IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
IS MEASURE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTION BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATE SOME REMEMBER LIKE
CLOTHES.
YES THIS IS THE THIRD PAST SEVEN
ATTEMPTS -- TO GET CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILT WE HAVE
STRUGGLED AS THE LEGISLATURE TO
GET BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
BADLY NEEDED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THIS IS JUST A WAY.
TO INFORM PEOPLE WITH BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT CALIFORNIA IS A
GREAT PLACE TO INVEST.
THANK YOU ARE WITH THAT SAID I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR A WHILE.
I'M LOOKING TO SUPPORT THIS BUT
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS BUT
WE'LL SEE HOW THINGS GO ON THANK
YOU THE MOVE FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT IS THERE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
WELL MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND.
A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND --
WITH THAT SECRETARY CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
VOEPEL.
LEVINE HI LEVINE I COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE COOPER AYE COOPER AYE
FUNK [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
NEVER [inaudible]
THE THE MEASURE THE OTHER
MEASURES OUT BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND I KEEP THE ROLE OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
SO WHAT THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR I WILL START WITH
MY EASIER BILL AB -- SIXTEEN
EIGHTY ONE PHONE NUMBER.
FIFTEEN A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE
SO WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
AB AT SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE WOULD
ELIMINATE THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF
EMPLOYED SUPERVISOR PEACE
OFFICERS AT KATE THROUGH TWELVE
AND ME COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
NECESSARY TO FORM THEIR OWN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT UNDER
EXISTING LAW BARGAINING UNITS
FOR SUPERVISOR PEACE OFFICERS AT
THESE DISTRICTS MUST HAVE A
MINIMUM OF TWENTY SUPERVISORY
OFFICERS.
ADD THERE ARE NO OTHER FORTY
NINE K. THROUGH TWELVE ANGRY
CULTURES TRICKS THAT MAINTAIN
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND ONLY ONE
IN PLACE MORE THAN A MINIMUM OF
TWENTY OFFICERS THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED.
IN THOSE REMAINING DISTRICTS ARE
THE SUPERVISORS OFTEN BELONG TO
UNITS REPRESENT MISCELLANEOUS
NON SWORN EMPLOYEES THIS MAY
RESULT LACK OF APPROPRIATE
REPRESENTATION SINCE PEACE
OFFICERS HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS
AND INTERESTS AND THOSE OF NON
SWORN EMPLOYEES.
CLASS FOR MY VOTE.
ANYONE ELSE SPORT.
THE RAINY PERIOD ON BEHALF OF
PORAC IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IS
MEASURE.
KOBE BECAUSE IDEAS OF WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TRUSTEE
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANYONE ELSE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
IT'S A NON ANY -- COMMENTS
QUESTION BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATE HEARING ON MEMBERS LIKE
TO CLOSE.
EVERY TRACK LASTS FOR NINE VOTES.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
AND I DO THANK THE MEMBER FOR
BRINGS FORD I DO WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL SO
SECRETARY LIKE CALL THE ROLL.
RODRIGUEZ HI RODRIGUEZ I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER [inaudible]
FONG.
FONG NO O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND HOLD THAT ON
WILL OPEN HOLD ON CALL SO WITH
THAT YOU'RE READY FOR NEXT.
ONE I'M ALWAYS READY FOR THE
NEXT.
ONE ALL OF YOU CLEARLY ARE NOT.
AB -- NINE SIXTY NINE IS MY
YEARLY EFFORT TO ALLOW OUR STAFF
THE SAME EXACT RIGHT THAT EVERY
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DEBTS AND
THAT IS THE RIGHT IF THEY SO
CHOOSE. TO ADD.
COLLECTIVELY BUT IT TO YOU
FORMER UNION COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN I THINK IT IS THE HEIGHT
OF HYPOCRISY THAT WE CONTINUE --
TO INSURE THAT.
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYEES HAVE THAT RIGHT IN
pCALIFORNIA AND WE I ATTESTED
BEAN -- SUPPORTIVE OF THAT RIGHT
YET OUR OWN WORKERS DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE THE ABILITY -- TO
TO EXERCISE THAT RIGHT AND SO AT
IT LAST YEAR BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD AND I A I THINK THEY'RE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
WERE CONCERNED THAT IT WAS A
BILL THAT I ONLY SUPPORTED --
THIS YEAR WE HAVE TWELVE CO
AUTHORS SO IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE
IS A GROWING DESIRE IN THIS
BUILDING -- TO GIVE WORKERS A
VOICE ON THE JOB INCLUDING OUR
OWN JOB SITE I WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
HAPPENED IN THE LAST YEAR THAT
REALLY SHOW US HOW IMPORTANT A
BILL LIKE THIS IS.
A BETTER NOW SAYS TALKS AT
INTERESTINGLY ABOUT NOT KNOWING
WHAT PEOPLE COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED FOR I ANYONE WHO'S
BEEN INVOLVED IN IN CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS KNOWS THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS BEYOND
WAGES.
THAT THAT WORKERS US SOMETIMES
BARGAINED FOR OBVIOUSLY I'M
WORKPLACE RULES SAFETY STANDARDS.
CALENDARS YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S
A A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WORKERS SHOULD HAVE A VOICE ON
THE JOBFOR AND I WOULD NOTE IN
PARTICULAR THAT IF I WERE
REPUBLICAN STAFF AND SAW WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE LAST ELECTION.
WHEN -- A NUMBER OF THEM
SCRAMBLED TO FIND OUT WHAT THEY
WERE GOING TO DO WITH OUR FUTURE
THAT PERHAPS THOSE RULES LAID
OUT A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT WOULD HAVE PROTECTED
THEM A LITTLE BETTER.
THAN ARE OUT WILL STATUS NOW I'M
OUR WORKERS DESERVE THE RIGHT TO
BE INCLUDED IN THE DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE HAD OVER THE LAST YEAR
WHEN WE SAY WE OF FIXED.
WHICH WE HAVE NOT -- SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ISSUES IN THIS
BUILDING THAT WAS UNILATERALLY
DONE BY MEMBERS BY THE BOSS IN
AND PLACED UPON THE WORKERS
WITHOUT THEIR INPUT EXCEPT FOR
MAYBE AN ANONYMOUS SURVEY WHICH
WE ALL KNOW.
OUR MOST OF OUR WORKERS DO NOT
BELIEVE WAS TRULY ANONYMOUS SO
THE FACT THAT WE RUN AN
ORGANIZATION THAT.
ARE NOT ONLY DOESN'T ALLOW
WORKERS TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINING UNIONIZE BUT ALSO AT
BELIEVES THAT -- WE ARE EXEMPT
FROM MANY OF THE WORKPLACE RULES
THAT WE HAVE DEFINED IN LAW IN
AN OFTEN -- THAT IS THE RESPONSE
OF ROLES WHEN WHEN WE HAVE
WORKERS OR THEIR SUPERVISORS GO
AND ASK WHY WE HAVE A CERTAIN
SITUATIONS IT IT IS OFTEN THE
RESPONSE THAT WE ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO THE ON STATE LAWS THAT WE
ACTUALLY PASS.
SO ONCE AGAIN.
ME AND MY TWELVE CO AUTHORS I
ASK FOR AT LEAST A MOTION TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORKING THIS BUILDING A
ONE OTHER.
NOTE ON THE ANALYSIS AS WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT PEOPLE WANT THE RIGHT
TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN AND THAT
IS.
HUMOROUS OF COURSE WE NEVER KNOW
IT AND THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT
IT WOULD BE UP TO THE WORKERS TO
DECIDE IF THEY WANTED.
TO JOIN A JOINED TOGETHER FORM A
UNION AND COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
SO WE ARE JUST ASKING FOR ODD
THIS COMMITTEE. TO MOVE ALONG A
BILL THAT WOULD GIVE OUR WORKERS
THAT VERY BASIC RIGHT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
WE WANT TO APPLAUD THIS ACTIVE
DOLLARS FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
AGAIN.
LET'S SAY A PLOY EASE OUR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AND THEY SHOULD BE
GIVEN.
ALL THE ALL THE RIGHT AND POWER
TO BE ABLE TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN.
OUR STATE IS GOVERNED BY THREE
BRANCHES STATE LEGISLATIVE AND
JUDICIAL STATE AND YOU THIS
EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN ALREADY
GRANTED THE THE THE POWER TO THE
TO UNIONIZE.
IT'S TIME TO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEE TO THAT
SAME I'M GONNA KEEP MY COMMENTS
SHORT BECAUSE I HAVE TO
COLLEAGUES HERE I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE MY TIME WITH THEM
THANK YOU.
NEXT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SERRA
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND WE ARE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT
SIMPLY GIVES WORKERS.
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHETHER THEY
WANT TO HAVE A UNION AND
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN -- AND SO
WE ARE SO IN SUPPORT OF THAT
RIGHT FOR EVERY WORKER I ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE STAFF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION OUR UNION -- WE HAVE
TWO UNIONS I AM ACTUALLY A
MEMBER OF THE PACIFIC MEDIA
GUILD LOCAL -- THIRTY NINE FIVE
TWO ONE WE NEGOTIATE WITH AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL I HAVE HAD THE
HONOR OF SITTING ACROSS THE
TABLE FROM ART PULASKI AND ANGIE
WAY -- TO NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT
WHICH IS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
EXPERIENCE AND WE GET THE WORK
OF THE FEDERATION DONE WE HAVE
TWO BARGAINING UNITS WE HAVE A
GREAT CONTRACT WE NEGOTIATE
EVERY YEAR.
IT'S BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
EXPERIENCE TO BOTH REPRESENTS
UNION WORKERS AND WORKERS WHO
WANT A UNION AND ALSO TO BE PART
OF THAT PROCESS MYSELF -- AND TO
SEE WHAT IT'S LIKE TO COME
TOGETHER WITH MY CO WORKERS.
AND DECIDE WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
US WHAT WE PRIORITIZE WHAT ARE
THE THINGS THAT WE NEED ON THE
JOB AND EVEN AS WELL PAID
PROFESSIONAL WORKERS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE ISSUES IN OUR WORKPLACE AND
IT IS SO MUCH BETTER TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THEM COLLECTIVELY AS
A GROUP.
THAN INDIVIDUALLY ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THAT IT WOULD BE WITH ART
PULASKI.
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
MISSION CHAIR MEMBERS KOBE
PRESIDING -- WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS CAN I WORK IN THIS
BUILDING FOR A DECADE AND AND I
SAW FOR TOO MANY TIMES TOO MANY
THINGS HAPPENED THAT SHOULD HAVE
NEVER BEEN ASKED OF STAFF --
THIS BILL WOULD DEFINITELY
ADDRESS THE WORKING CONDITIONS
SITUATION AS WELL AS PAY
DISPARITIES AS WELL AS ALL THE
OTHER ISSUES THAT.
COME UP WHEN YOU DO NOT HAVE A
CONTRACT BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY I
THINK THE WORKING CONDITIONS
ISSUE IS PROBABLY SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE A BARGAIN IN
NEGOTIATED -- WITH STAFF AND THE
EMPLOYER SO WITH THAT AND FOR
ALL THE PREVIOUS REASONS STATED
WE'RE IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
MEANWHILE PORT.
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MEGAN
SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS -- OBVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES THE FRONTLINE
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BARGAIN OVER WORKER PROTECTIONS.
AND SO WE THINK THAT SAME -- IT
SHOULD BE APPLIED TO WORKERS
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE WE'RE IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER TED TED
TOP AND FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT STRONGLY AND SUPPORT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
ISN'T JUST IMPORTANT TO
EMPLOYEES IT HAS.
FUTURE WILL BENEFITS FOR
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
AS A FORMER LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEE
IN THIS BUILDING AS WELL IT
WOULD BE.
A GOOD PROCESS TO BRING TO THE
BUILDING AND TO GIVE EMPLOYEES A
VOICE IN THEIR WORKPLACE.
ANYONE ELSE'S WORK YEAH MICHELLE
CAST OF THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION I THINK
EVERYONE'S MADE THE REALLY GOOD
POINTS ABOUT THE NECESSITY FOR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND THE
RIGHTS.
OF EMPLOYEES TO ORGANIZE AND WE
SEE NO REASON WHY THESE GROUP OF
WHEN UP GROUP EMPLOYEES MEN AND
WOMEN SHOULD BE EXCLUDED FROM
THAT RIGHT WE ASK FREE EITHER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
ANY.
COMMENTS CONCERNS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEN HERE IN.
M. I WENT THANK YOU I ALSO WANT
TO BRING UP EITHER WAS IT.
A MENTION IN THE NOW SAYS ABOUT --
PROPOSITIONS THAT LIMIT OUR
BUDGET TERRY ART BECAUSE
BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS AND I WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT -- ALL OF OUR
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE UNIONS DEAL WITH
THAT OF COURSE IN THEIR OWN
BARGAINING ON WHETHER IT'S
BECAUSE OF PROP NINETY EIGHT OR
BECAUSE OF THE STATE BUDGET --
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
THE UNIONS TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION OBVIOUSLY I WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS HAVE -- COOPER THIS BILL
THIS YEAR AT ASSEMBLY WOMAN AS
BURNER **** BATH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA KALRA MCCARTY SALAS A
MARK STONE CERVANTES TEAM WICKS
BONTA CARILLO IN SENATOR DRAW SO.
ALSO NOTE ON THAT LIST THAT
THERE ARE TWO MEMBERS -- ALONG
WITH MYSELF OBVIOUSLY WHO
STARTED IN THIS BUILDING AS
ENTRY LEVEL STAFF -- FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
SERVING UNDER LEGISLATORS AND
AND AND FOLKS WHO MIGHT BE.
GOOD BENEVOLENT -- BOSSES AND
YET THEY SEE THE NEED -- TO
ALLOW WORKERS THIS VERY
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT I THINK I AM
AS WE MOVE FOR IT WHAT ONE THING
THAT WAS SAID IS IT'S GOOD FOR
EMPLOYEES BUT IT'S GOOD FOR
EMPLOYERS TO AND I WOULD NOTE
THAT.
HAVING AND I THINK ANY OF US WHO
HAVE EVER TRIED -- TO TO REPLACE
STAFF ON ON OUR TEAMS KNOW THAT
AS OUR HR DEPARTMENT IS NOT SET
UP TO UNDERSTAND HOW.
TO NEGOTIATE THAT PROCESS IN A
WAY THAT THAT MAKES SENSE OF
FEAR OF LAWSUITS THAT FEAR OF OF
PUBLIC EXPOSURE MAKES THAT
UNCLEAR FOR BOTH THE WORKER AND
THOSE OF US WHO ARE TRYING TO
GET THE RIGHT.
I'M WORKPLACE BALANCE SO EVEN
WITH BECAUSE WHERE UNDER A UNION
EMPLOYEE OF EMPLOYMENT CONTRACT
IT'S VERY CLEAR ON THE PROCESS
BY WHICH YOU GO THROUGH THERE'S
A GRIEVANCE PROCESS THERE'S A
WAY IN WHICH THE EMPLOYER HAS
CERTAINTY AT AND AND WE DON'T
HAVE THAT THE BUILDING.
AS LEGISLATORS AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE PIECE
TO NOTE HOWEVER AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
BOTTOM LINE IS I'M DOING THIS
BECAUSE AS MY STAFF WOULD LIKE
THE OPTION OF COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINING.
I DON'T THINK THAT THEY WANTED
BECAUSE I'M IN A BAD EMPLOYER I
DON'T THINK THEY WANT IT BECAUSE
I SOMEHOW DON'T LISTEN TO THEM.
BUT THE TRUTH IS THIS NO MATTER
HOW MUCH I LISTEN TO THEM I
CAN'T AFFECT WORKPLACE RULES IN
THIS BUILDING.
SO AS AS GOOD AS I AM TO THEM I
I CAN CALL RULES AND ASK I CAN
COLLECTIVELY BAG FOR CHANGES --
BUT WE CAN'T HAVE A TRUE VOICE
WE AS LEGISLATORS DON'T HAVE A
TRUE VOICE ON EMPLOYMENT
PRACTICES IN THIS BUILDING.
ALL ON WORKPLACE SAFETY ISSUES
ON ON UP CALENDARS IN IN AND
RIGHTS IN SO YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
HELPLESSNESS THAT OUR WORKERS
ARE EMPLOYEES FEEL THAT THEY
CAN'T COME TOGETHER AND VOICE
THEIR OPINION WITHOUT
RETALIATION WITHOUT WORRY.
AND ACTUALLY HAVE SOME LEVERAGE
TO MAKE CHANGES TO THAT THAT'S
WHAT WE WANTED TO HEAR I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING TO BE
AFRAID OF AND I THINK UP AGAIN
IF WE DON'T WANNA BE HYPOCRITES
AND WE WANT TO LIVE OUR VALUES.
THAT WE TREAT OUR OWN WORKERS
LIKE EVERY OTHER WORKER IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AT LEAST A MOTION BUT AND I
DON'T EXPECT.
ONE WHAT THANK YOU REMEMBER YOUR
TRULY BENNETT A TRUE CHAMPION
FOR WORKERS AND IN ALL TYPES OF
OCCUPATIONS NO LASHER THIS BILL
CAME TO US BEFORE CAN.
AT TOWARDS THE END REALLY EVEN
GET A CHANCE TO LOOK AT I DID
SUPPORTED WITH THE CURSOR VOTE
LAST YEAR.
THIS TIME WE HAD MORE TIME TO
LOOK AT IT I I KNOW WE'VE WE'VE
HAD SOME MORE ISSUES COME ABOUT
THE CONSTITUTION ISSUE WITH.
PROP ONE FOURTEEN OTHERS WHAT
THAT -- THINGS THAT MAYBE HAVE
ME LOOKING AT A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE NOW.
SO FORTY BECAUSE OF THOSE ISSUES
I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME.
SO JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BRINGS FOR TO BE THAT
CHAMPION AND WITH THAT SICK AS
WELL FIRST ONE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MOTION SECOND I'M.
OKAY WITH THAT SAID THERE IS NO
SECOND IN A MOTION.
SO THEY WILL NOT BE A OF ROLE ON
THAT ROLL CALL ON THAT SO
WITHOUT.
WHAT IS OUR NEXT THE BILL WE
HAVE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
SO
-- WE ARE VERY PATIENTS ARE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
JONES SAWYER.
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT BOTTOM
NUMBER NINE A.. TEN OH SEVEN SO
THANK YOU AND YOU ARE READY SIR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB TEN ZERO SEVEN HELP STATE
EMPLOYEES BY PROVIDING CERTAINTY
IN THE DISCIPLINARY TIMELINE.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS UP TO THREE
YEARS TO COMPLETE AN
INVESTIGATION THAT MAY I REPEAT
MAY RESULT IN EMPLOYEE
DISCIPLINE.
THAT MEANS THAT A STATE EMPLOYEE
PLATE REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THEY COMMITTED IN IN
INAPPROPRIATE ACT MUST PUT THEIR
CAREER ON HOLD.
FIRST UP TO THREE YEARS THEY CAN
NOT.
REQUEST A RACE.
REQUEST A TRANSFER OF PORT FOR
FOR PROMOTION. FOR THE MORE IN
CASES WHERE AN IMPROPER ACTION
HAS OCCURRED THIS MEANS YOU CAN
TAKE UP TO THREE YEARS BEFORE AN
EMPLOYEE IS EVEN DISCIPLINE.
ALLOWING THEM TO REPEAT THEIR
BEHAVIOR WITH THAT HE CORRECTIVE
ACTION.
REDUCING THE TIME NECESSARY TO
DISCIPLINE THE STATE EMPLOYEE TO
ONE YEAR PROVIDES EMPLOYEES
CERTAINTY ALLOWS MORE TIMELY
CORRECTIVE ACTION.
AS A FORMER SUPERVISOR IN PUBLIC
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR THAT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS JOHN
LEVEL REPRESENTING THE STATE
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. FOR
CANNELLA IMPORT CONNECT.
THANKS I DON'T OVERREACH FROM
BUT REACH HERE THE CALIFORNIA.
GOOD.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
LEVEL ON THE LOBBYIST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION.
WITH ME IS FORD CANNOT WHO CAN
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT MAY COME UP ON THIS.
THIS IS AS MISTER JONES SAWYER
INDICATED A MATTER OF
FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS RIGHT NOW
YOU HAVE. THREE YEARS TO RESOLVE
A DISCIPLINE.
OF THE HUMAN CONDITION BEING
WHAT IT IS PEOPLE HAVE A
TENDENCY TO TAKE THE WHOLE THREE
YEARS.
AND THAT DOES INCREDIBLE HARM TO
THE EMPLOYEE AS MISTER JONES
SAWYER IS POINTED OUT.
HERE SHE IS VIRTUALLY FROZEN IN
THEIR CAREER DURING THAT TIME
AND EVEN IF AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
IT IS DETERMINED THAT -- HEY
THERE WAS NO FAULT -- EVERYTHING
IS FINE NO EVERYTHING IS IN FINE
YOU GAVE THREE YEARS OF YOUR
CAREER WHERE YOUR ABILITY TO
ADVANCE YOUR CAREER HAS BEEN
UNFAIRLY -- CURTAILED.
THE ONE YEAR -- A PER OF
PROVISION IN THE BILL WORKS VERY
VERY WELL WITH PEACE OFFICERS
RIGHT NOW THERE IS A ONE YEAR --
WINDOW AND THAT HAS WORKED
EXTREMELY WELL AND IT SHOULD BE
TRANSFERRED ACROSS -- CITY AND
OF EMPLOYMENT -- THIS COMMITTEE
HAS VOTED.
FOR PREVIOUS BILLS -- ONE
AUTHORED BY MISTER JONES SAWYER
THAT ALSO ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY.
THANK YOU NEXT A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M FOR CANNOT
ADMINISTRATIVE LIAISON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION WE
REPRESENT SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS AND DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS.
AND A DEPARTMENT SHE'D HOSPITALS.
OF ATOMIZED.
SEVEN OF MY SEVENTEEN YEARS --
OF HANDLING CAGES FOR OUR
MEMBERS WE'VE HAD MEMBERS
SITTING IN ROOMS FOR TWO YEARS
NOT DOING ANYTHING.
JUST LIKE REVIEWING GARBAGE AND
THEY MIGHT BE OF OF SUPERVISING
SOCIAL WORKER OF DR -- ALL KINDS
OF THINGS WAITING FOR A IT -- AN
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THEY WERE
ACCUSED OF INEFFICIENCY OR
INDISCHE.
USUAL NEGLECT OF DUTY OR SOME
SMALL MINISTRY OF VIOLATION.
AND THE WE'RE WE'RE LOSING A LOT
OF THEIR EXPERTISE ON THE JOB
FOR THEM SITTING AROUND AND NOT
DOING ANYTHING FOR A COUPLE
YEARS.
PLUS THERE ARE THEIR LIFE IS IS
BEEN PUT ON HOLD.
NOW IT'S KIND OF FUNNY WHEN I
LOOK AT THIS BECAUSE THE ISSUES
THAT THIS BILL ALLOWS THREE
YEARS FOR WHICH IS FRAUD
EMBEZZLEMENT.
OF SEXUAL RESIDENTS SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
ALL THOSE THINGS -- MOST
AGENCIES WOULD JUMP ON MEDIATE
LEE AND THEY'D BE DONE WITHIN
SIX MONTHS.
EVEN THOUGH IT THE BILL ALLOWS
UP TO THREE YEARS FOR THOSE
ISSUES BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET
COMPLICATED.
BUT ALL THE ADMINISTRATIVE
VIOLATIONS THE LITTLE -- LITTLE
VIOLATIONS -- WE DON'T WE
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HOLD PEOPLE
HOSTAGE FOR THREE YEARS OF
FOREIGN OF SMALL VIOLATION THAT
THEY WANT TO INVESTIGATE.
PLUS.
IN MY DEALINGS WITH THEM WILL
THEY GET TO STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD ALMOST FOUR YEARS LATER.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO HAVE GO
THROUGH SKELLY.
AND THEN THEY WANT TO APPEAL IT
TO THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD.
THE WITNESSES FOR THE STATE AND
OF THE EMPLOYEE OR CHOIR --
OFTEN NOT AVAILABLE THE RETIRED
MOVE DIED -- DON'T REMEMBER FOUR
YEARS AGO A. H. IT'S JUST A OF A
KIND OF A FARCE.
AND NOT THAT WE DON'T WIN THE
KATE MIGHT MY GROUP WINS THOSE
KIND OF CASES ALL THE TIME.
AGAINST THE STATE IS IT THE
ISSUE IS MORE HURTING PEOPLE AND
WE'RE NOT -- JUSTICE DELAYED IS
JUSTICE DENIED SO THIS WEEK AN
AND DISTRICTS NOT THE AMERICAN
WAY OF DOING THINGS.
SO -- EITHER DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
REMOVE THE BELL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TED TOP AND
FOR THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPERVISORS.
AND THE PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS%
IN CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT FOR THE
REASONS THAT HAVE BEEN VERY WELL
STATED.
THANKS THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ANY
COMMENTS CONCERNS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAY IN AN AREA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES OF RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND A JUST
QUICKLY SAY AND IN SOME WAYS
THIS IS KIND OF PERSONAL TO ME
AS A SUPERVISOR FOR THE CIVIL
LOST HIS.
FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS.
OUT I'VE EVEN HAD EMPLOYEES NOT
SHORT FOR YEAR.
AND WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS FOR THREE
YEARS.
AND THEN WHEN THEY WENT THROUGH
THE SCALY HERE AND GOT TO THE
PERSONAL COMMISSION.
THEY WERE REINSTATED.
I LOST PRODUCTIVITY -- TAXPAYERS
MONEY IS WASTED -- IT'S JUST.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING I DON'T
KNOW IT IS BAD IN THE STATE AND
SO -- FROM IN SOME WAYS IT'S
PERSONAL TO ME AND SO HOPEFULLY --
WE CANNOT AYE VOTE ON IS SOME OF
THE SPORT.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AS WELL AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING HIS RUN
THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT SAID WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
MOTION AND A SECOND SECRETARY
LIKE CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
AYE VEGAS I VOEPEL NOT TOLD IN.
PROPONENT VOTING LEVINE.
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE COOPER
[inaudible]
FONG.
O'DONNELL RIGHT.
GENERAL I I WILL KEEP IT OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU.
BRUCE MORTON [inaudible]
FOR YEAH [inaudible]
RUN A THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER
COOPER HERE TO PRESENT I FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B. SIX SIX
FOR WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
CURRENTLY THE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT LAW NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ACT ALLOWS FOR PERMANENT
INCAPACITY STATUS FOR ITS
MEMBERS.
THIS STATUS IS DETERMINED THE
TIME RETIREMENT IN ONLY EXCUSE
ME IF CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE MET.
THEN THE NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN
X. SYSTEM RETIREMENT BOARD'S
GRANT OR DENY.
PERMIT CAPACITY STATUS
DIFFERENTLY DEPENDING ON HOW TO
INTERPRET THE LAW.
SB SIX SIX FOUR ADDRESSES
INCONSISTENCY FOR ASSISTANCE THE
SECOND OF COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
SB SIX SIX FOUR WILL CREATE A
FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM FOR THIS
CURSE FOR ALL PEACE OFFICERS.
REGARDLESS OF THE CLASSIFICATION.
SB SIX SIX FORCE PERSPECTIVE
REMAIN SUBJECT TO ALL SCORERS
PROCESSES.
AND MEDICAL EXAMINATIONS SB SIX
SIX FOUR PROVIDES.
TIME TO STUDY THE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM
THE FAIRNESS PROTECTING
EMPLOYEES WHO IMPROPERLY
INCAPACITATED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY.
AND I HAVE TO WITH THIS IS WITH
ME -- BAD PRESENT A SECOND OKAY
LAW ENFORCEMENT MANNERS SO SHE
XIN.
OF THE TENTH TAUGHT THE SEN IT'S
IN YOUR SO SHE OF THEM STANDING
OFFER STEVE WELTY.
GO AHEAD.
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THE PURSE
COMMITTEE I'M TAUGHT THE SOME
PRESIDENT OF THE SACRAMENTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX SIX
FOUR AND HAD THE UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCE OF HAVING A MEMBER
RETIRE OUT WITHOUT THE
PROTECTIONS THIS BILL.
WOULD PROVIDE.%
I REMEMBER WAS A LONG STANDING
EMPLOYEE OF THE DEPARTMENT WHO
LIKE MANY OTHERS SUSTAINED
INJURIES THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER.
WHILE PROVIDING SERVICE TO THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY AND
RESIDENTS OF THIS GREAT STATE.
HE PROMOTED THROUGH THE RANKS
EVENTUALLY RETIRING OUT AT THE
RANK OF LIEUTENANT.
OUR MEMBERS SUFFERED AN ON THE
JOB LOWER BACK INJURY FOR WHICH
HE UNDERWENT SURGERY.
THE SURGERY WAS DEEMED A FAILURE
BECAUSE HE SUFFERED NUMBNESS IN
THE LAMB'S WEAKNESS AND A LOSS
OF CONTROL.
PRIOR TO OUR MANAGER SEEKING
RETIREMENT THE MEMBER RECALL
PARTICIPATING IN EVENTS SUCH AS
TAKING COMBAT CEDRIC'S INTO
CUSTODY.
ASSISTING WITH A VEHICLE FIRE
PHYSICALLY BREAKING UP FIGHTS.
HOLDING POSITION TOM PERIMETER.
AND CHASING BURGLARY SUSPECTS TO
NAME A FEW.
AFTER ALL OF THE SERVICE HE WAS
DENIED A PERMANENT DISABILITY
RETIREMENT BASED ON HIS POSITION
AS A MANAGER.
IT IS MY HOPE THE LET'S THIS
LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE
SECURITY FOR MEMBERS SO THEY CAN
FOCUS ON SERVING THE COMMUNITY
AT THE TIME THEY'RE CALLED THE
DUTY REGARDLESS OF THEIR STATUS
AS A MANAGER.
THESE EMPLOYEES GIVE SELFLESSLY
WITHOUT REGARD FOR THEIR OWN
SAFETY AND YES.
OCCASIONALLY WE ARE INJURED.
DESPITE HOLDING THE POSITION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT MANAGER WE ARE
STILL REQUIRED TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF GOVERNMENT CODE.
TEN THIRTY ONE TO BE FOUND FREE
FROM PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL AND
MENTAL CONDITIONS.
THAT MIGHT ADVERSELY AFFECT.
THE EXERCISE OF POWERS OF PEACE
OFFICER.
IT IS ONLY FAIR THEY HAVE THE
SAME PROTECTIONS THOSE ARE NON
MANAGERIAL MEMBERS OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT FAMILY AND
RETIREMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND WHILE SUPPORT.
YEAH I JUST.
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE ADVISED LOOKING.
OVER A HUNDRED THE RETIREMENT OF
HILL MANY OF THOSE WITH SCORERS
SOME OF THOSE WITH WITH GUY
CAPTAINS AND LIEUTENANTS -- FROM
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT ASKED.
FOR AND SO A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
MOVE THE BELL.
SEE NONE NOW WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND -- ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBER COMMENTS SEEN HERE NOT.
SOME REMEMBER LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALL PEACE
OFFICERS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
RANK OR ASSIGNMENT REQUIRED TO
CARRY OUT THEIR DUTIES.
IN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS SB SIX
SIX FOUR WILL GIVE SCARES THE
CLEAR AUTHORITY TO GRANT
PERMANENT AND CAPACITY.
BY RECOGNIZING THAT REGARDLESS
OF THE PEACE OFFICERS RINKER
ASSIGNMENT MAYBE CALL UPON A
TIME TO FORCE THE LAW.
OR RESPOND TO EMERGENCY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT THE SOME
REMEMBER I APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THIS BEFORE TO GOOD BILL I'M
LOOKING FOR TO SUPPORT IT.
AND WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND SECRETARY LIKE
CALDERON.
RODRIGUEZ FIVE RODRIGUEZ I WILL
BILL.
VOEPEL I LEVINE.
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE COOPER HI
COOPER AYE FONG.
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE.
THE MOTIONS OUT BUT WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OF AND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
WHERE IS MY TALKING? TO HELP
WITH THAT
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB ONE ZERO
ZERO TWO SIR.
THANK MISS CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB. TEN ZERO
TWO WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
THE CCPOA REPRESENTS THE HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN WHO KEEP
OUR CORRECTIONAL FACILITY SECURE.
THIS MEASURE IS INTENDED TO
MEMORIALIZE THE CCPOA ITS.
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING IN
THE CASE REGULAR IN IN CASE THE
REGULAR BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS ARE
UNSUCCESSFUL.
THESE AGREEMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT ARE RETIRED
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS HAVE
ADEQUATE HEALTH BENEFITS AFTER
THEIR SERVERS.
WITH.
WITH ME TODAY IS GOVERNMENT CUE
FROM CC PRO I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO IS SAID
THE AUTHOR INDICATED GAVIN MCCUE
ON BEHALF OF CCPOA -- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AS A
VEHICLE FOR ARE POTENTIALLY
VEHICLE FOR EMMA YOU AND AGAIN
I'M HERE TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
MOVE THE BELL [inaudible]
IN THE COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
ANY COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I WILL TELL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING LEVINE.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE FONG.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE [inaudible] ONE
CALL [inaudible]
EVEN WITH.
THE SERGEANTS CAN CALL THE
REMAINING MEMBERS RING THAT.
FRIENDSHIP THE ROLE.
ON THE BILL SOME VOTES LIFT THE
CALL [inaudible]
EXACTLY [inaudible]
WHO WINS?
WE STRUGGLING TO DISCARD ONE NOW
I THINK WITH THE MEMBERS WE HAVE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
I NEED TO GET NEXT DOOR.
ONCE WE'RE DONE. FOR THE CLIENT.
FOR THE MEMBERS OF OUR HIM LIFT
THE CALL ON THE CONSENT --
CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR WAS -- FATAH
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B..
THREE SEVEN TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE A. B.. SIX SIX FOUR SIX
FOUR FORMS ARE FAR NUMBER.
FIVE SB SIX SEVEN TWO AND FOUND
FOURTEEN A. B. FORTUNE -- FIFTY
TWO SENATOR LEFT THE CALL ON THE
MISSION MEMBERS [inaudible]
LEVINE.
COOPER -- COOPER AYE FUNK.
I THINK I'M GOOD I THINK THE
MODEL.
SO THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
WE CAN NOT [inaudible]
CALLING AGAIN.
QUITE AN OPEN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE SUMMER FONG I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'RE HERE. TO TO VOTE.
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR FONG
[inaudible]
ON HI.
THE MEASURES OUT SO LET'S GO
AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALL ON CALL
I'M NUMBER FOUR A. B.. SIX SIX
FOUR COOPER.
SECTOR CALL THE MISSION MEMBERS
[inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
FUNK [inaudible]
FONG I OKAY WITH THAT -- FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX DIED TO LACK OF
A MOTION.
SIR GO TOO FAR NUMBER EIGHT AB.
TEN ZERO TWO SECRETARY CALL OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE COMMISSION
MEMBERS.
LEVINE [inaudible]
FONG.
THE WORLD OF THE COLUMN FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TEN ZERO
SEVEN SECRETARY CALLED THE
MISSING MEMBERS [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
COOPER.
COOPER I FONG [inaudible]
FONG NO.
THE MEASURE IS OUT -- NEXT ONE
FIVE NUMBER.
ELEVEN AB TWELVE HUNDRED
PATTERSON SECRETARY CALLED
MISSION MEMBERS [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible] FIVE COOPER I
IN THAT MEASURES OUT
[inaudible]
THE STORE.
WITHOUT DOUBT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWELVE TWELVE LEVINE
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
THE MEASURES OUT.
OUR NEXT ONE FIVE NUMBER
THIRTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE WORKS SECRETARY CALLED
MISS AMERICA.
LEVINE [inaudible]
COOPER.
COOPER I FONG [inaudible]
FONG NO.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
OF THE LAST ONE IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN AB SIXTY NINETY
ONE GONZALEZ.
SECRETARY CALLED MISSING MEMBERS
VOEPEL.
NO.
THE BILL NOW LEVINE.
COOPER. TWO FOR HI.
AND THAT MEASURES OUT.
IT IS WITH THE THE SERGEANTS
CONCERT TRY TO OUR CONTACT
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LEVIN'S OFFICE
IF YOU CAN -- JOIN US CONNALLY
GROUP OF ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GO AHEAD AND OPEN
THE ROLE A WILL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B..
THREE SEVEN TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE A. B..
SIX FOUR FOUR FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB.
SIX SEVEN TWO AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
FOURTEEN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO
SECRETARY.
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
LEVINE [inaudible] THIRTY NINE A
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT.
OF THE NEXT ONE IS FILE NUMBER
FOR A. B..
SIX SIX FOUR SECRETARY OPEN THE
ROLE.
LEVINE.
LEVINE HI.
AND THAT MEASURES OUT.
THE NEXT ONE IS -- FAR NUMBER
SIX DIED TO A LACK OF A OF A
MOTION SO GO OVER TOO FAR NUMBER.
EIGHT A. B. -- TEN TO LEVINE
[inaudible]
LEVINE I SELECT WHAT A PHONE
NUMBER NINE AB.
TEN ZERO SEVEN SEARCH OUR OPEN
THE ROLE LIVING.
LEVINE I'M THAT MOTION IS OUT.
WITH THAT NEXT ONE FAR NUMBER
ELEVEN A. B. TWELVE HUNDRED
PATTERSON.
SECTOR OVER THE ROLE ON THE
PHONE FOURTEEN LEVINE.
LEVINE I MEAN THAT MEASURES OUT.
NEXT ONE FIVE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
A. B..
TWELVE TWELVE WHICH I THINK YOU
GOT THAT ONE WRONG THAT MEASURES
OUT.
NEXT ONE IS FROM THIRTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE OF THE ROW.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I THAT MEASURES OUT.
AND THE LAST ONES PHAM FIFTEEN
A. B..
SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE CENTER OVER
THE ROLE OF LIVING.
LEVINE HI AND WITH THAT THAT
MEASURES OUT.
WITH THAT SAID OUR MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU